momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela
empezamos hablando sobre los efectos
provocados por el cob y 19 porque la
pandemia devolvió una década el nivel
educativo de américa latina' cuéntenos
sí señor andrés muy buenas noches mire
la crisis económica belkovich 19 hará
que unos 17 millones de alumnos de los
últimos cursos de secundaria y de los
primeros de universidad se vean abocados
a abandonar sus estudios por lo menos
así lo dice la organización de estados
iberoamericanos en un informe que
resalta que 180 millones de alumnos de
la región estuvieron confinados
ese impacto de periodo de brisa que
supone un impacto en pérdida de
competitividad y productiva de la región
va a ser una región más pobre en el
futuro y que las competencias y
habilidades que tengan estos chicos y
chicas van a ser más débiles por lo
tanto su futuro laboral va a ser mucho
más dificultoso y con menos digamos
capacidad de retribuciones que que otros
que no han sufrido este digamos impacto
una pandemia andrés otra de las cosas
que dice el informe es que la educación
a distancia no se ha podido generalizar
según la cepal independientemente de si
más hogares tienen o no acceso a
internet sólo 3 de cada 10 tienen acceso
a un software educativo países como
república dominicana perú méjico panamá
o colombia no llegan ni siquiera al 30
por ciento de cobertura manera vamos a
perú porque el gobierno devolvió al
congreso la ley de retiro anticipado de
pensiones en ese país andrés al igual
que en chile el legislativo ya aprobó un
tercer retiro anticipado de los ahorros
de los fondos privados de pensiones esto
como medida excepcional de apoyo a los
trabajadores pero el presidente
francisco sagasti objetó la ley porque
la considera en contra
y ahora el congreso debe corregirla el
gobierno está de acuerdo con que el
retiro máximo sea de 17 mil 600 soles o
unos 4 mil 575 dólares al precio de hoy
pero quiere ponerle ciertas limitaciones
a la medida por ejemplo sugiere que sólo
puedan acceder al retiro quienes no
tengan aportes por al menos tres meses
consecutivos hasta el 30 de abril de
este año así no retiran quienes no lo
necesiten también dice que se deben
eliminar un artículo que les permite a
los mayores de 40 años que no hayan
hecho aportes en cinco años consecutivos
accederá al cien por ciento de su ahorro
más noticias de la región daniela y es
que en bogotá hubo protestas de
trabajadores de la vida nocturna
cuéntenos porque andrés desde djs hasta
cocineros meseros y dueños de bares se
quejan de las nuevas restricciones para
sus actividades a medida que el país
como sabemos lucha con un fuerte aumento
en los casos de coronavirus hubo hasta
platos rotos en el piso para expresar su
frustración con las políticas económicas
de la pandemia que incluyen en esta
ocasión cuarentena para los fines de
semana y toque de queda
a todas las noches hasta el 9 de mayo
según la asociación de comerciantes
fenalco más de 27.000 bares y
restaurantes han cerrado desde que
comenzó la crisis escuchemos
la noche el entretenimiento nocturno las
mujeres y hombres que dependen de esta
economía nocturna no pueden seguir
pagando los platos rotos ni de la
pandemia y de las malas decisiones
enfocadas a la noche no estamos
dispuestos a soportar un cierre más no
aguantamos más
y la vamos a italia porque a italia que
presentó al parlamento su plan de
recuperación el gobierno de mario draghi
reveló en que se va a gastar 221.500
millones de euros de los cuales la gran
mayoría viene del fondo europeo de
recuperación 168 mil millones como vemos
en el gráfico que son el 30 por ciento
del total irán para la transición
ecológica muchos países de europa le
están justamente apostando a las
energías renovables para la etapa post
crisis otra quinta parte será para
fomentar la transformación digital y la
modernización del sistema productivo la
investigación y educación tendrán
partidas por más de 30 mil millones así
como la infraestructura momento de
conocer los indicadores wall street en
cerró mixto pero anotó récords en dos de
sus principales índices el nasdaq
tecnológico y el standard and poor's a
europa a cero al alza gracias a un
repunte en los precios de los metales
que impulsó a las mineras y en américa
latina hubo resultados dispares méxico
reportó caída por el mal desempeño de
sus grupos aeroportuarios y nuestra
cifra del día 191 98 millones de dólar
a esta cifra subió el gasto militar
mundial en 2020 con un aumento de 26 por
ciento frente al año anterior según el
instituto internacional de estudios para
la paz de estocolmo en eeuu canadá y
brasil aumentó pero en general en sur
américa cayó andrés daniela muchas
gracias por traernos la información
económica aquí en france 24 y ustedes
muchas gracias por acompañarnos quédense
con toda nuestra programación
[Música]